Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Je viens vous présenter une filière, une
filière, mais qui travaille dans le BTP.
Je ne vais pas vous vendre du sable.
Je suis là pour vous parler
d’une matériauthèque.
Une matériauthèque, c’est comme
une ressourcerie, une recyclerie.
On n’y trouve pas de meubles,
on n’y trouve pas d’assiettes,
par contre, on y trouve du placoplâtre,
on y trouve des huisseries,
on y trouve des éléments de toiture.
Pour donner un exemple de ce qu’on
peut y trouver, c’est un exemple en PVC.
Il y a un an de ça était détruit
un bâtiment qui n’était pas très loin.
C’était un immeuble de quatre étages
qui avait été rénové il y a cinq ans,
qui avait été rénové avec une belle
enveloppe, mais qui n’a jamais été loué.
Une enveloppe neuve et quatre ans
plus tard, elle était détruite.
Aujourd’hui, c’est ce qu’on retrouve sur
notre plateforme, notre matériauthèque.
Ce qu’on vend, ce sont ces huisseries
qui ont été démontées
et qui valent encore le coup.
La France reçoit 70% de ses déchets
du monde du BTP -
bâtiment et travaux publics.
Il y a 42 millions de tonnes
qui sont créées par le bâtiment.
On a les mêmes taux à peu près
en Auvergne-Rhône-Alpes.
Nous, à notre petite échelle,
depuis deux ans qu’on existe
avec nos deux salariés,
on a réussi à éviter
l’enfouissement de 71 tonnes.
On en est très fiers.
Ce n’est qu’un début,
j’espère qu’on ira beaucoup plus loin.
(Applaudissements)
On est en Europe
et il y a un code de l’environnement en
Europe qui dit que pour gérer les déchets,
il y a plusieurs manières, mais il y a une
hiérarchie dans cette manière de faire.
Au départ, on fait du réemploi,
de la réutilisation, du recyclage.
Et puis quand tout ça, ça ne suffit plus,
on appelle ça l’enfouissement
ou éventuellement l'incinération.
De ces manières de faire, de ces manières
de gérer ces soi-disant déchets,
dans le BTP, il est très important de
séparer ce qui est recyclage de réemploi.
Pourquoi je le dis ? Parce que ce
n’est pas au même niveau qu’on agit.
Le recyclage, comme vous voyez ici,
c’est un grand cercle
où on prend des matériaux d’un côté
qui sont aujourd’hui des déchets,
on va les broyer, on va les compacter,
on va en refaire autre chose.
Le réemploi, on prend, on époussette,
on passe un coup d’éponge et on repose.
C’est beaucoup plus rapide
et c’est beaucoup plus intéressant.
Nous, dans notre matériauthèque,
on est là-dedans,
c’est ce qu’on va faire
avec le PVC par exemple,
ces huisseries en PVC.
L’avantage du réemploi dans le bâtiment,
c’est que déjà ça fait beaucoup moins
d’énergie utilisée pour la même chose,
ça coûte effectivement moins cher,
et en plus de ça, le réemploi dans le BTP,
à la différence de l’enfouissement,
c’est plus que 100 fois plus
d’emplois possibles
pour traiter ces millions
de tonnes de déchets.
De notre côté, on trouve que le réemploi
a quand même pas mal d’avantages
quand on peut réutiliser des choses.
Notre projet, il est venu
d’auto-constructeurs effectivement.
On se disait : « On va partir au nord
de Clermont, on va aller au sud d’Issoire,
pour trouver des matériaux
grâce au Bon Coin.
Pourquoi ne pas massifier
tous ces projets, tous ces matériaux ? »
On a ici beaucoup de propriétaires et de
maîtres d'ouvrage qui ont des bâtiments
et qui vont devenir une ressource
pour nous, pour vous.
Ce projet-là, il est certes encore jeune,
on n’en est qu’à 71 tonnes.
Ceci étant dit, nous, en 2030, ce qu’on
souhaite et ce qu’on aimerait en Auvergne,
c’est que tous les propriétaires
des bâtiments, de patrimoine,
et toutes les personnes qui se disent :
« Tiens, j’ai un projet de construction,
j’ai un projet de rénovation »,
se disent :
« Je vais faire du réemploi, l’intégrer
dans ma déconstruction pour le futur,
récupérer des matériaux
ayant eu une première vie
et les utiliser pour ma future véranda. »
Cette fenêtre en PVC dont je
vous parlais tout à l’heure ?
J’espère qu’elle va être réutilisée,
que ça fera partie de vos projets,
et je vous en remercierais vraiment.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)